dix mille personnes se sont rassemblées
à paris au trocadéro sous la bannière
voté pour la planète elle a répondu à
l'invitation de nicolas hulot et des ong
vertes
nicolas hulot souhaitait selon sa propre
expression administrer une piqûre de
rappel aux candidats signature de son
pacte écologique c'est si la ronge et
alexandre dupont nicolas hulot acclamé
comme un candidat qui briguait l'elysée
sur l'esplanade du trocadéro
dix mille personnes sont venues écouter
son scénario catastrophe pour la planète
auprès de l'animateur télé
beaucoup d'artistes lebesson à vis marc
lavoine pascal obispo
tous soutiennent le grand retour de
nicolas hulot sur le devant de la scène
son but forcer le faste écologique au
coeur de la campagne présidentielle
aucun acquis sociaux social pardon ne
pourra résister à la combinaison de la
pauvreté de l'effondrement nos
ressources naturelles et des
conséquences en cascade et imprévisible
des changements climatiques le
réchauffement de la planète le
développement durable relégué aux
oubliettes
qu'à cela ne tienne depuis quelques
jours nicolas hulot rencontre les
candidats et leur rappelle leurs
engagements d'hier nicolas sarkozy lui a
même promis s'il est élu font
d'organiser dès septembre un grenelle de
l'environnement je préfère avoir déçu
quelques personnes en ne présentant pas
quand avoir déçu beaucoup en présentant
et en n'étant pas forcément à la hauteur
de leurs espoirs
une démarche qui fait lui militants des
people
moi j'ai une fille et j'aimerais bien
que dans cinquante ans qu'en juillet
j'ai vu une baleine elles me disent oui
ça bien sûr qu'elle comprenne ce que je
veux dire
nicolas hulot sait que c'est quelqu'un
qui dit la vérité voilà tout simplement
et la vérité c'est la nourriture de
l'esprit donc on est content on est
rassasié commentant ce à quoi ils ont
dans la foule
josé bové rester en retrait il fait
partie des cinq candidats s'ils ont
signé le pacte écologique
mais pour le 22 avril nicolas hulot ne
donne aucune consigne presse juste voté
pour la planète